He was one of the world's most notorious and ruthless leaders.
Since coming to power.
In 1979 Saddam used any means necessary to hold onto Iraq,
including killing anyone who stood in his way at a young age.
He was brutalized at home,
ran away to his uncles,
and quickly became a thug for an extremist political party.
As he rose through the ranks and took over,
he modernized the country and rules through fair.
Eventually,
his greed defines and murderous ways.
Let him to the gallows.
Today on biographics,
we learned about the life of Iraq's former presidents,
Saddam Hussein.
On April the 28th 1937 Saddam Hussein was born to a peasant,
women in a modern Straw village.
Goals our near to Chris on the banks of the Tigris river,
so darn bore the physical marks of his tribe on the rest of his right hands at
our two of three dark blue dots.
Most people in this village lived in severe poverty and life was very difficult,
so the arms father,
his sheep herd a disappeared before he was born.
Then a few months later said arms.
12 year old brother died from cancer or this scent.
Saddam's mother suffer into a crippling depression and she attempted to abort
unborn baby and to kill herself.
She failed and when her infant son was born,
she named him Saddam,
which means in Arabic,
the one who confronts or the stubborn one without a husband.
Soon Dylan's have the means to support our baby.
She sends it on to live with a brother,
Kai Rolla to laughy retired army officer and is Arab nationalist and to Chris
[inaudible] lives with him only three years until it's alpha was in prison due
to his part in a coup to overthrow the pro British governments in Iraq.
By this time said I'm his mother had remarried,
a man named Abraham Hassan.
Villagers knew him as Hassan for Leia back at his mother's home,
the young Saddam and do regular beatings and maltreatment of the hands of a
stepfather,
neighbors,
and early friends of Saddam.
Recall Hassan beating him to wake him in the morning and regularly shouting
things like you,
son of a dog out,
don't want you.
He was forbidden from going to school and instead was made to be useful by
stealing goats and chickens for the family.
If Saddam was caught stealing it has been said he would rather poison the
animals then return them to their owners.
At the age of 10 Saddam Dom,
his uncle had been released from prison as he fled to to Chris to be with him.
Topher filled the boy with dreams of glory saying he would be a great leader of
Iraq.
Someday you're going to have to sit on his first real possession.
And that was a hand gun.
So dom reportedly use the weapons threats in his primary school teachers and he
may have murdered a man and he was not even a teenager.
According to the story,
after the killing,
police showed up at [inaudible] house and founds it,
I'm sleeping with the gun,
still warm under his pillow,
under his uncle's cat was finally able to go to school,
but he lands much more than how to read,
how to write through the years.
He was deeply influenced by Kalfas politics.
And after leaving the [inaudible] secondary school in 1957 at the age of 20 so
dom drawings the Arab about half socialist party as a low level thug and gunman.
The party was formed in Syria in 1947 with the ultimate goal of unifying the
various Arab states in the Middle East.
At the time it was the most radical nationalist party in Iraq and did it become
an underground revolutionary force,
but he was 22 Saddam played a major role in the Ba'ath Party.
His assassination attempts of the Ven Iraqi Prime Minister Abdul Karim Qassim.
During the attack on October the seventh 1959 Saddam and other assassins
ambushed Cassim's car on Baghdad's busiest street.
The prime minister minister's a chauffeur was killed,
but the prime minister was sped surviving gunshot wounds in the arm and
shoulder,
so they'll escapes with a bullet in his leg.
The official version of the story portrays it on as a hero who dug the bullet
out with a pen knife and other versions suggests to the plot fails because
Saddam opened fire prematurely.
Several of the would be assassins.
They were caught,
tried and executed,
but Saddam was not.
He managed to flee to Syria before eventually seeking refuge in Egypt.
While in Egypt,
studied law at the University of Cairo.
Saddam returned to Iraq in 1963 after a successful military overthrow of cosines
governments.
After his returns was recruited for yet another assassination,
the Ba'ath party at suffered from infighting and the coup was plans to overthrow
the leader.
The plan,
however,
was betrayed and Saddam became a wanted man.
He was forced into hiding,
but was caught and in prisons in 1964 while he was in prison,
he remains active in party politics and read up on his role models tyrants like
Joseph Stalin and Hitler.
In 1966 Saddam escaped prison,
thanks to the help of sympathetic prison gods.
Afterwards,
he was appointed deputy secretary of the regional commands and became a rising
star in the bar off organization.
In 1968 another successful coup in Iraq puts it down as but AAFP party in power
and precedents.
Ahmed Hassan,
our backer,
Saddam's cousin named him deputy head of the secret police.
Saddam proved to be a ruthless but effective politician within governments.
He either eliminated or cooperatives individuals seem stood in his wife.
Eventually he clawed his way to become the vice president of Iraq's
revolutionary command council,
the RCC,
the core group that held Iraq's behalf,
this government together,
although not the official presidents of Iraq rock until 1979 so though I'm Trudy
held the reins from the early 1970s onwards.
When the Ba'ath party it seized control.
It did not enjoy widespread support across the country.
That changed after Saddam nationalized Iraq's oil industry in the early 1970s
before the energy crisis of 1973 as a result,
the nation enjoyed a boon to the economy and as the massive earnings allow the
back office to governments to fund health,
education and public works sectors and expand social programs.
In an attempt to wipe out illiteracy,
Saddam required all children to attend school and made it free through high
school.
He also provided free hospitalizations,
all the Rockies and full economic support to the families of Iraqi soldiers.
Such reforms were unheard of in any other Middle Eastern country in the years
before.
The Iran Iraq war construction became one of the prized occupations of Iraq is
middle class.
It is also important to note that 40% of the increased revenue from oil to
buying armaments from western and Soviet suppliers,
that figure increased at the onset of the war with Iran in 1979 when our back,
our attempt to to your night Iraq and Syria in a move that would have left
Saddam effectively powerless,
Saddam forced albacore to resign and on July of 16 1979 Saddam Hussein became
president of Iraq.
Five days later,
he calls him assembly of the Ba'ath party consisting of roughly 250 people.
Now,
the meeting party officials saft mystified as Saddam made the announcement that
he had uncovered a plot against him and he claims the conspirators were in that
very room and alleged informants then read a list of 68 names out loud and each
person was promptly arrested and removed.
Every single one of these individuals was eventually tried and found guilty of
prisoner 22 of them were sentenced to death.
The whole ordeal was films and circulated around Iraq.
This was an intentional well scripted display of Saddam is power and to clear
message of who was in charge.
Three months later,
Saddam declared 14 people up to 13 of the Jews,
part of a Zionist aspiring.
He made a very public carnival like display out of their execution,
stringing them up before a crowd of thousands in downtown Baghdad.
Over the next several months,
Saddam had more plotters murders on television and he hung them up on the city's
lampposts to guard against coups and ensure loyalty surrounded himself with his
Ken putting his fellow Klansman in government positions.
He regularly used informance and it's the secret police to route out a suspected
conspirators.
If anyone so much has made a joke about Saddam,
they could have that tongue caught out or even pay with our life.
He believed it was better to murder a person of suspicion and be wrong than it
was to not and then be killed by them.
Okay.
Does it all married his first cousin,
so his uncle TALF his daughter,
that five children,
including two sons who day and [inaudible] as well as three daughters.
Rock out runner Holler.
He took on mistresses but did not parade them around publicly.
Later on when his sons grew up,
he gave them high ranking positions within the Iraqi government to Dom's public
image was meticulously crafted.
He dyed his hair black,
sported a mustache and refuse to wear his reading glasses and that's in private.
He had a slight limp due to a slipped disk,
so he was never filmed walking for more than a few steps.
He was six foot tall and his weight fluctuated from trim to Chubby,
but as well tailored suits were made to disguise is protruding valley.
Each of his 20 palaces was kept fully staffed with meals prepared dany as if he
were in residence to disguise his whereabouts.
He moved around frequently and to use the body doubles to 40 assassination
attempts.
His meals,
she delicacies like imported lobster were first tested for radiation and then
poison.
His wine of choice was the Portuguese rosay but he never drank in public.
Do you maintain the conceit that he was a strict Muslim?
Saddam was particularly phobic about germs and even top generals,
someone to meet him.
What often order to strip down to their underwear and it's their clothes were
then washed arms and the x rayed before they could get dressed to see him.
They also had to wash their hands and disinfections during his imprisonment and
just said he would try to maintain this loneliness by wiping his utensils and
food tray with baby wipes before eating throughout his rule,
he maintains a limited worldview and possessed little knowledge of western
culture laws and advancements in technology.
He was once shocked to learn there was no such law in the u s that prevented
citizens from complaining about the presidents.
They'll sign you that Saddam anointed himself,
presidents of Iraq.
Iran is Ayatollah Khomeini that day.
Successful Islamic revolution.
So Darren's political power rested in part upon the support of Iraq's minority
sunny populace,
and he worried the developments and Shiites minority Iran,
because need to a similar uprising in Iraq and response on September the 20
seconds 1980 so dom ordered Iraqi forces to invade the oil rich region of
Kazakhstan stone and Iran,
a clear violation of international law.
The conflict seems,
turns into an all out war.
One Saddam foolishly expected would be over in a matter of weeks.
Saddam had no prior military experience and he grossly underestimated his enemy.
Iran was three times the size of Iraq and to formidable opponents a stalemate
and sued with both sides engaged in bloody trench wolf that at the same time at
ground troops with deadlocked sit on some millions of dollars into developing
nuclear weapons.
In 1981 Israel took this matter seriously believing that if Saddam had the
ability that would be no preventing him from dropping atomic bombs on their
cities.
In June,
the Israeli air force destroyed Iraq's research center or rentals.
Eric,
at least 25 pounds of enriched uranium were reported to have been on site.
The plants was near completion and scheduled to begin operations within a matter
of months.
The destruction of Iraq's nuclear plants was humiliating and with no end in
sight to the war.
Saddam consultant as cabinets in the meeting said Mom's health minister
suggested that he stepped down in order to form a ceasefire with Iran.
As the story goes,
said I'm thanked him for his cancer ends then had him arrested on the spot.
The minister's deeded with Saddam to release our husbands since he promised that
he would,
when he was sent home the next day he was delivered in a black canvas body bag,
cut up into tiny pieces in the closing days of the war with Iran.
Saddam's murderous ways reached new heights and it's most savage act.
He poisoned thousands of civilian Kurds using chemical gases,
killing upwards of 5,000 people and injuring 10,000 mall.
The genesis of what became known as the Halabi Gymnastica or bloody Friday,
Iranian photographer,
caviar Golstein witness the gas attacks from a helicopter.
He stages it was life,
frozen life had stops like watching a film and suddenly it hangs on one frame.
It was a new kind of deaf to me.
The off time off requests victims were still being brought in.
Some villages came to our shopper.
They had 15 or 16 beautiful children begging us to take them to hospital.
So all the press sat there,
and as we were each handed a child to carry,
as we took off,
fluids came out of my little girl's mouth and she died in my arms.
One decades after the attack,
at least 700 people were still being treated for severe after effects of this
massacre.
So these have concluded that the Kurdish population in this region that suffer
from a higher percentage of medical disorders,
birth defects,
and various diseases,
including cancers and heart disease.
On August the 20th 1988 after years of intense conflicts,
the left half a million casualties on each side.
A ceasefire agreement was finally reached.
The ATO war ravaged Iraq's economy and infrastructure.
1 million Iraqi soldiers were out of work at the ends of the 1980s so dom turned
his attention towards Iraq's wealthy,
neither Kuwait,
Saddam believed that the Kuwaitis had a $200 billion in various bank accounts
around the world,
and to takeover of this small country would yield him all the riches he needed
to pay back Iraq's ward out and stabilize this country using the justification
that Kuwait was historically a part of Iraq.
Saddam ordered the invasion on August the second 1990 it took only at six hours
for Saddam's armies to occupy the country and move greatly condemned around the
wells.
The UN Security Council resolution was prompted me past imposing sanctions and
setting a deadline of January the 15th of 1991 for the Iraqis to leave Kuwait
during the occupation.
So dom stage day number of bizarre televised interviews with citizens of key
ways in which he asked them if they were happy with the Iraqis invasion.
And of course in all of these interviews they said absolutely because they
didn't have a choice when's it on ignored?
The January the 15th deadline,
a coalition force headed by u s presidents,
George Hw Bush confronted Iraqi forces.
Saddam was no match for America's far power and modern warfare technology.
Within just six weeks,
Saddam's troops were out of Kuwait.
A ceasefire agreement was signed,
the terms of which included rock,
just man's Lincoln's germ and chemical weapons programs.
The previously imposed economic sanctions levied against Iraq remains in place.
Despite this and the fact that his military had suffered a crushing defeat and
estimated 150,000 Iraqis died.
So I'm claimed victory in the conflict.
He calls the mother of all battles his biggest victory and the maintains that
Iraq had actually repulsed and attack by America and it's criminal gang.
He says Iraq has punched a hole in the myth of American superiority and it to
the nose of the United States and the dust during the 1990 various she items
Kurdish uprisings in Iraq occurred,
but the rest of the world fairing and other war did little or nothing to support
these rebellions and as they were ultimately crushed by Saddam's forces.
At the same time,
Iraq remains under intense international scrutiny.
Saddam violated the terms of the USP steel when inspectors were sent into a
rock.
They found him destroyed stockpiles of weapons including chemical and biological
warheads and a super gun with missiles capable of reaching Israel.
The inspectors also alleged Saddam was still at work at developing nuclear
weapons in 1993 when Iraqi forces violated a no fly zone imposed by the UN.
The United States launched a damaging missile attack on Baghdad.
Further strikes.
Okay.
I didn't.
1998 with economic sanctions still in place in the years following the Gulf War.
Saddam,
it continued to maintain his personal wealth and his family's wealth through
selling oil and medical supplies meant for his people on the black market.
While the citizens of Iraq,
we're in dire straits,
he built opulent palaces and has maintained his lifestyle
after the terrorist attacks on the US.
On September the 11th 2001 President George W.
Bush and members of his administration suspected Saddam's governments of having
a relationship with a solid lardons Alica your organization.
They also suspected him of possessing weapons of mass destruction and is
January,
2002 state of the Union address,
President Bush named Iraq,
part of his so called axis of evil along with it wrong and it's North Korea.
Later that year,
you and inspections of suspected weapons sites began.
There's little or no evidence that such programs existed was actually found
despite this on march the 20th 2003 under the pretense that Iraq did in fact
have a covert weapons program and that it was planning attacks.
A US led coalition invaded Iraq.
Within weeks the government and military had been toppled.
And on April the ninth 2003 backed out fell to the Saddam.
However,
he managed to a you'd capture in the month that follows and intense search for
Saddam began.
While in hiding,
Saddam released several audio recordings in which he denounced Iraq's invaders
and called for resistance.
Finally,
on December the 13th 2003 so dom was found hiding in a hole in the ground in a
bunker near a farm house and add door near to create the ones well dressed and
groomed.
Leader looks the Shovels Unshaven and bewildered.
When he was arrested.
Saddam was moved to a US base in Baghdad where he would remain until June the
30th 2004 when he was officially handed over to the interim Iraqi government to
stand trial for crimes against humanity with his day's numbered,
so dominant,
showed no accountability or remorse for his crimes.
In 2003 when Austin by Iraqi politicians about his brutal acts,
Saddam Coles,
the Heloc Jerry attack Iran was handiwork,
said the Kuwait was rightfully a part of Iraq and is that the mass graves were
filled with thieves who fled the battlefields.
Saddam declared that he had been just that fun because Iraqis needed a tough
ruler.
During his trial,
Saddam would prove to be a belligerent defendants,
often boisterous.
He challenging the court's authority and making bizarre statements.
On November the fifth 2006 Saddam was found guilty and sentenced to death.
The sentencing words appeals,
but ultimately upheld by the court of Appeals.
On December the 30th 2006 it camp a justice and Iraqi base and Baghdad.
Saddam was executed.
He was then buried and Allah his birthplace on December the 31st 2006 this close
the chapter on one of modern day histories,
most tyrannical,
and it's brutal dictators.
So I really hope you enjoyed that episode of biographics.
If you did this,
a couple of things you could do right now.
One is hit that like button below.
Also,
if you want more stuff like this,
we put out brand new videos every Monday and every Thursday,
so hit that subscribe button below and subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on Youtube.
If you actually want to get a notification about these videos,
please do hit that bell button next to the subscribe button and that'll send you
a notification every time,
every Monday and Thursday when we put out a new video.
Also,
if you want to watch something else right now,
stuff from the archive over there on the race,
and as always,
thank you for watching.